Speaker 1: Hey, this next story, I don't even
fully understand this story. I'm hoping we can
try to figure it out together. There's a pro Trump
election clerk named Tina Peters accused of not
counting ballots in some local races. So like
this would be actual election fraud carried out
as pro trump election fraud. It's being
investigated. She is reportedly now being hidden
by my pillow CEO, Michael Lendell. There's a
story in The Daily Beast about it. And the article
explains that during PETA's first year as clerk
in Mesa County in twenty nineteen, her office
was blamed for leaving more than five hundred and
seventy uncounted ballots in a box long past an
election they just didn't count on. Less than a
year later, one of her office's Dropbox's leaked
ballots, sending some floating in the summer
breeze. Like I'm not talking about a metaphorical
leaked that they they just got caught in the wind.
The ballots were floating around in the air. OK,
now Pieters has gone underground, reportedly
hiding in a safe house provided by Mike Lyndell
after she allegedly participated in a breach
of Mesa County voting machine data this year.
That data soon wound up on conspiracy websites,
making Peters a folk hero among the MAGGA set
and the subject of an FBI investigation.
Peters, who did not return requests for comment,
took office in twenty nineteen after her
predecessor reached the term limit. What
followed was an unusually bombastic
tenure in a typically low drama role.
While overseeing the November 20
19 general election, Peters office
forgot to count five hundred and seventy four
ballots, leaving them unattended in a Dropbox
outside her office for a month. That slip up
coincided with a rush of departures from Peter's
office in December of twenty nineteen. Nearly 20
of Peter's thirty two person staff had departed.
Most more staff quit days after missing ballots
were discovered, bringing the departure count over
two dozen. The Colorado secretary of state's
office told Peter to get our act together,
the secretary of state's office appointed
someone to be in the clerk's office to help
with the election. Patti in show, a Democrat, an
experienced former Mesa County clerk employee,
was hired to help Peters with elections,
but just two months into Intro's role.
Peters fired her, accusing her of not doing
assigned work. An allegation in show denied
the rift turned ugly. Peters staffer filing a
criminal complaint against then show for allegedly
not working during a pandemic. And the latest
now is that Peters reportedly is hiding out in a
house rented or provided by my pillow CEO
Michael Dell. It's it's all just crazy and
it's crazy on a few fronts. Number one, the
side that is regularly alleging the voter fraud
seems to be the side regularly caught allegedly
allegedly committing it. And then, of course,
Mike Pillow's involvement in all of this just
makes such little sense. We're going to try
to get more information about the story. But
that's the latest. As I understand it right now